[Música]
tiempo para repasar la economía aquí en
directo América edición nocturna Para
ello contamos una noche más con nuestro
compañero Juan Pablo lucumir Juan Pablo
vamos con Twitter Qué se sabe de las
últimas noticias respecto a la compra de
esta red social Buenas noches de Rodrigo
pues iniciamos hablando de la noticia
que se conoció hace unos minutos por los
medios locales de Estados Unidos y los
musk acaba de asumir como nuevo jefe de
Twitter y tomó el control de la red
social esto sucede mucho antes de la
hora en la que se había acordado que
pues se cerrara el trato entre ambas
partes programado para mañana viernes a
las 5 de la tarde hora Nueva York pero
qué más se sabe hasta ahora que sabemos
de lo que hará este Magnate con Twitter
pues previamente hemos había visitado
las instalaciones de Twitter y pidió a
los ingenieros ya había pues dado
algunas órdenes de la red social que no
realizarán cambios en el código de la
plataforma a partir de mediodía de San
Francisco de de mañana viernes cuando
pues esperaba que se oficializara esta
compra esto para que no haya ningún
cambio antes de la multimillonaria pues
transacción que se iba a hacer entre
ambas partes no olvidemos que se ha
comentado mucho sobre las cosas que
mosca haría con Twitter y es algo en lo
que pues él casi ya disfrutado publicar
y también a alardeado en las redes
sociales nada más para mencionar un
ejemplo no sé si usted se acuerda por
ejemplo este jueves cuando anunció la
confirmación de la compra público que
compraría Twitter para tratar de ayudar
a la humanidad a quien amo eso fue lo
que dijo y es que la mayoría de esos
anuncios han sido bastante polémicos en
abril preguntó a los usuarios si querían
un botón para editar los tweets después
de ser publicados y en la encuesta ganó
el Sí una vez también tuiteó que odiaba
la publicidad pero recientemente dijo
que Twitter Ink será la plataforma de
publicidad más respetada esto en un
intento de ganarse también la confianza
de los compradores la opción alterna la
publicidad era Buscar ingresos por medio
de suscripciones bueno parece que no es
ama ilonmax Pero hay una cosa que
preocupa realmente a los trabajadores la
compañía y es saber si mantendrán el
supuestos de trabajo precisamente ayer
miércoles
mosc dio tranquilidad a los empleados de
la empresa y dijo que no planeaba
eliminar el 75% de los puestos de
trabajo porque ya se había Pues rumorado
que precisamente eso era lo que él iba a
hacer bueno Y estos anuncios de hilo más
del hombre más rico del mundo muchas
veces han alterado ya los mercados
mundiales Así es Y menos mal en este
momento las bolsas están cerradas porque
pues hay noticias de último momento pero
veamos el como el comportamiento
bursátil de Twitter luego del anuncio de
most la empresa Tuvo una ganancia del
0,66%, pero los informes de ganancias de
otras grandes tecnológicas también
Hicieron que sus acciones se vieran
afectadas meta la casa matriz de
Facebook e Instagram tuvo un desplome
del 24% después de Mostrar resultados
financieros decepcionantes entre enero y
septiembre tuvo casi los mismos ingresos
que el año pasado pero sus utilidades de
se desplomaron en un 96% debido a que
sus gastos operativos también se
dispararon las acciones de Amazon
también se desplomaron hasta casi un 15%
Pero esto fue posterior al cierre de las
bolsas de este jueves una reacción que
llegó tras el informe de pérdidas de
ingresos la empresa dijo que su
inversión sigue enfocándose en que los
paquetes lleguen cada vez más rápido a
los usuarios que pues es lo que Todos
queremos cuando pedimos en Amazon Intel
fue otro de los perdedores también y
Juan Pablo vamos ahora a las bolsas
europeas y a las de la región cómo les
ha ido a ellas pues las bolsas europeas
estuvieron medidas por el anuncio del
Banco Central de aumentar las tasas de
interés en 75 puntos básicos dejándolos
tipos en 2%. esto en una movida para
frenar la inflación de la zona Euro que
se acerca al 10%. en nuestra región las
bolsas cerraron en terreno mixto la
bolsa de Buenos Aires tuvo su quinta
jornada consecutiva en positivo mientras
la Bolsa Mexicana perdió un
0,88%. pues después de las cifras de las
bolsas vamos a Estados Unidos y a uno de
los datos económicos del día y es que
parece que por el momento esquiva la
recesión Así es Estados Unidos por el
momento se salva la economía de Estados
Unidos se expandió con fuerza en el
tercer trimestre del año con esto entre
julio y septiembre la economía
estadounidense creció 2,6% Comparado con
ese mismo periodo del año anterior y
superó por dos décimas las estimaciones
de los analistas con este dato de
Estados Unidos oficialmente sale de la
recesión técnica en la que se encontraba
porque según la teoría económica Rodrigo
se registran cuando se registran
contracciones en la economía por dos
trimestres ahí es cuando se considera
una recesión este anuncio incluso puede
que beneficie al presidente Joe biden
luego de múltiples informes negativos
que había salido en su contra como el de
la vivienda la inflación y el desempleo
que todos nos hemos reportado aquí Sí
desde luego uno de los temas importantes
para las próximas elecciones de medio
término Muchas gracias Juan Pablo lucumi
parece que repaso económico vamos ahora
con directo a vamos
[Música]